well good evening what a beautiful
uncensored evening it is the sun is
shining the birds are singing all seems
right with the world
well that didn't last long did it yes
summer has barely started when all
hell's about to break loose if you're
going to get a train in the uk next week
well forget it millions of people across
the country just trying to go about
their businesses
are facing utter chaos because rail
workers are striking over pay and jobs
and they say it could go on all summer
these 50 000 workers will walk out
meaning fewer than one in five trains
will run network rail estimates that
these strikes will cost the rail
industry up to 150 million well
transport secretary grant shan said the
strike could lead to rail workers losing
their jobs
i appeal directly to rail workers who i
think are less militant than their union
leaders
don't risk striking
don't risk the industry and your future
don't risk striking yourself out of a
job
don't pitch yourself against the public
well joining me now is the rmt union
boss mick lynch who's responsible for
all the mayhem that's about to come away
mr lynch good evening to you
good evening yeah i suppose my question
is this we've just come through a
two-year pandemic
we have the appalling after effects
rippling through europe from war in
ukraine we've just about got over the
fractured
mayhem of brexit
and now just when it looks like the sun
is literally coming out and people can
start to feel hopeful and positive about
life along come you
uh and you're gonna cause complete chaos
and mayhem
for the british public for the
foreseeable future and i only ask you
why do you think this is the right time
to do this
well the sun's not gonna shine and i am
members appears if they lose their jobs
they're facing pay cuts in relation to
living standards
and they're facing having their
conditions ripped up we've been engaging
with these employers
and indeed the department for transport
and various ministers for more than two
years since kovid commenced back in
march 2020
and we've put to them last december that
we needed the issues addressed they've
told us that thousands of jobs are going
to be removed from the railway by
compulsory redundancies if necessary and
that the pay freeze is going to continue
now we haven't had any offers on the
issues at stake they've had plenty of
time to resolve these matters
and many of our members are going into
the third year now where they've not had
a pay a pay deal
any increment on their money at all so
we don't want this dispute but we needed
to to make sure that the message was
given that we're not going to accept
our conditions being ripped up and being
driven into a form of fire and rehire
akin to pno which we also dealt with
and we think the government is taking
the opportunity of covid the same as the
aviation industry has done to try and
strip out jobs strip out conditions and
make people casualized across the uk and
it's a phenomenon that we're faced with
insecure work
precarious work and we're not going to
accept that we're going to fight for our
right listen i understand you're
fighting for your workers i do and i'm
not against unions per se and i've
supported actions in the past when i
felt that they're justified and they're
well timed it's the timing of this it's
the fact that so many ordinary people
going about their ordinary lives are
going to be facing complete chaos for
the next week and maybe many weeks after
that just at a time when everyone's
starting to feel a little bit better
about life and i would put it to you if
you're putting the devil's advocate
position on this the government has
pumped billions into the rail industries
it has many other industries throughout
the
carnage of the pandemic uh network rail
says they've not announced any job cuts
and will find job savings by not
replacing employees who leave the
organization through voluntary
redundancy obviously i i guess that's an
arguable point between you and then
you're after an 11
rise for your members some of whom as
you know not all but some of whom are
trained drivers earning 54 000 pounds a
year uh now i would say to you look i'm
not against your workers being protected
by you
uh you're doing your job but when it
comes to pay rises following a pandemic
why are we not giving nurses 11 pay
rises
police
well we were on the front line we our
members worked all the way through the
pandemic they were driving trains mate
they were driving trains they were
fixing tracks they were signaling trains
they were cleaning trains not the same
as you know it's actually saving lives
that's my point it's all considered
if it was gonna be dishing out public
money when there's very little public
money to dish out surely you would
accept that health workers for example
should be first in the line they were in
the real front line not trying to
respond to that i'll try and respond to
that uh piers if i can
our members work through the covid they
were on the front line and railway
workers died and transport workers died
as a result of being at work during that
period now we're not asking for
compensation for that all we're asking
for is a pay increase that reflects what
we've done
uh during that period and the cost of
living we're also asking that we don't
have our conditions ripped up and our
jobs stripped back network rail are
making these cuts and they have put to
me directly across the table a proposed
cut of 2 900 uh track workers directly
they've done that face-to-face so it's
just not true that they haven't proposed
job cuts but isn't that isn't that a
different issue which is an issue of
technology that they believe they have
technology now which will actually be
safer than having human workers on the
track potentially risking their lives we
deal with technology all of the time
peers ever since the stephenson's rocket
we've dealt with changing the railway
industry but we must do that in an
environment of agreement not in position
now if it comes to the question of other
workers and there are many deserving
workers and the british worker needs a
pay rise and we're part of the trade
union movement and we want all workers
to have a pay raise they can't all get
11.
can they 11 percent
members do without their pay nurses
won't get a pay rise bin workers won't
get a pay rise care workers won't get a
pay rise what will happen is the train
operating companies and others who made
500 million pounds of profit last year
in the worst year of trained revenues
500 million they took out they will just
get increased profits two of the
companies i'm dealing with right now are
subject to takeover bids because they're
so profitable first group which is one
of the chief train operating companies
made over 2 million a week last year
go ahead is subject to a takeover where
they're bidding
highly inflated share prices at 14 pound
50 an hour these people are making a
killing and it won't go to uh nurses and
other uh people that deserve it will go
into the profit margins of these
companies i've been watching you doing
interviews for the last couple of weeks
and you're passionate about it and again
i don't i'm no problem with you trying
to do the best job for your workers but
you've been banging on a lot about
there's too many rich people in the
country you know you earn 124 000 pounds
a year right i mean that's not i don't
that's not a small i don't know that's
your salary package right no it's not my
salary is eighty four thousand pounds a
year that's the total package
well the the the total package includes
tax and national insurance and pension
contributions well everyone salary is
eighty four thousand i'm very happy with
that everyone's package includes that
are you talking about yeah well what's
your package
well i would hope more than yours
why didn't you tell everyone what you
were you're like
well i'll tell you why because i'm not
actually leading out my members i don't
have any on a strike which is going to
cause huge inconveniences to the british
people the majority of people in this
dispute are earning between 25 and 31
000 pounds some are only 54 000 are they
some probably earned more than that
the median salary for a railway worker
that we're covering in this dispute is
thirty one thousand pounds a year the
train drivers can get fifty four
thousand or more whale engineers can get
like around thousands i mean a lot of
your workers and good money and my point
is really at a time of economic crisis
when people are literally
struggling to feed their kids when food
bank queues are getting bigger is this
the right time for you to be holding the
country to ransom for 11 pay rises well
we're not holding anyone for action
well if you let me answer the question
are you going to let me answer the
question i am we haven't asked anyone in
this dispute for an 11 pay rise we've
pointed out that inflation the rpi is
currently 11.1 at the point we should
have done a deal with network rail it
was 7.1 and last year it was 0.9 other
companies it was around 7.5 to 8
so let's get that straight we're not
asking for 11
you are quoting that figure because you
are you want that to be in heaven
that's where inflation is going and it's
going above 11
and if we don't get a pay rise this year
we'll have lost out for maybe between
50. i want to show you more
just in relation to your personal
enumeration do you not think there's a
slight inconsistency between saying
there are too many rich people in the
country and we're going to take all
their money away and you earning a
shared load of cash i've never said that
there's too many rich people what i've
said is that they're the the super rich
in this country have never been richer
we've got more billionaires than we've
ever needed and if we want to get equity
in this country we need to restructure
that and that means the british worker
getting a pay rise
are you are you uh are you he's set by a
vote are you a vm are you a millionaire
i'm not a millionaire no really
what really no i'm not i spent 38 years
on the tools as an electrician appears
before i got elected quite a few years
of 120 grand in package that's that adds
up quite quickly isn't it
no well not particularly no the majority
of my life i've spent on the tools as an
electrician as a railway worker
so
so i work for whatever my union decides
and they do that by a vote of the
members i'm not saying you don't deserve
it i'm saying if you're going to start
talking about there are too many rich
people it's a little bit you're saying i
said there were too many rich people i
didn't say there were too many what i
said was there have never been more
super rich people right well now you're
talking about semantics let me let me
see well i'm not talking too much
about what i said you say there are too
many rich people there are too many rich
peoples what you say
well i haven't said that what i've said
is that there's an imbalance in this
society between people who are super
rich who are getting the benefits of
dividends and shares and that needs to
be sacrificed a wee bit so that the rest
of the people in this country can get a
pay rise for the work that they do now
you're including health care
workers council workers low paid people
under the country let me let me show you
what i believe is your facebook page i
want you to confirm or deny it this is
your facebook page
it's a picture
of the hood from thunderbirds can you
see the likeness
well i'm just wondering where the
comparison goes because he was obviously
an evil criminal terrorist mastermind uh
described as the world's most dangerous
man who
that is a joke amongst me and my friends
and you can see the likeness if you like
so you're not denying that you are
comparing yourself to the hood
i'm not comparing myself to anyone i'm
me you've literally made your profile
picture the hood and i'm simply saying i
was a massive if it was
the most dangerous
person in the world
he's the most evil puppet made out of
vinyl in the world is that the level
your journalism's at these days i simply
asked you if that was you and your
facebook page would you do do you think
i look like the most evil person in the
world pierce now you're asking me to
answer a difficult question mick i don't
know you that well all i'm saying is you
must be the only person in the world i
think i'm a working class bloke who's
leading a trade union in a dispute over
jobs
pay and conditions i understand if you
don't want to be compared to the hood
probably better not to have the hood
that's your profile i think it's quite
funny
so do i but i also like as i was a
thunderbird
though don't you want to talk about the
issues rather than a little vinyl
trying to get inside the mindset of the
man about to wreak havoc on the country
it makes me laugh honestly that you have
the hood as your profile pic because
that's a man who wreaked havoc on the
world well it makes me laugh that your
level of journalism has descended so far
that you can't think of any other
question rather than uh
yeah but you've chosen to spend two or
three minutes of this interview talking
about irrelevance because you seem so
irritated
because you seem so irritated by the
comparison i'm not irritated at all i'm
completely you seem very irritated
well i'm not you're not
this is your non-irritated face is it
what point are you trying to prove piers
i mean i'm not sure if you're trying to
win
you put it on your facebook page i'm
simply asking it's an odd choice for a
union boss okay who's about to go on a
series of structures to have this
thing to say about the issues that we
face
i i've made my feelings clear i think
that you are entitled to your job but i
think when your job starts to impact
massively on millions of people in this
country just at a really hard time for
the country i think you've mistimed this
and i think if you spend the whole
summer causing discontent then i think
you're misreading the mood of the nation
well what we're trying to do is get a
settlement to a dispute and we will do
that and we'll work with all of the
companies involved and we'll work with
the government if they want to come to
the table to try and get a settlement to
the dispute which is a serious one
because i think many working class
people in this country are fed up of
being exploited and they're fed up with
low pay they're fed out of precarious
work and being vulnerable to the
changes in society that they've been put
through and the economic model that
we've got which is outsourced
and no conditions in their work we need
to change that and that's what this
dispute is part of attempt to rebut not
against children
negotiating at all
on behalf of your members all i would
point out to you uh finally is that
grant shaps
does bear a striking resemblance to
virgil from the thunderbirds and from
memory as a fan of the thunderbirds he
actually took out the hood
well the hood came back every week
and maybe that's a message he's got to
take that everyone was in it every week
and then you know you see a relationship
you see now you're right now you're
rising proudly
right now you're proudly proudly
positioning yourself as the hood uh mick
lynch good to talk to you you want to go
go there
i didn't want to go there you you went
there
but good to talk to you
i'm getting the hook i'm getting the
hood evils there